wait a minute this can't be right this
cannot be right
this is so dumb i'm just gonna let's
just let's just mix it up i was told not
[Music]
this
hi my name is ryan and i am going to try
and cook carbonara pasta and i'm claire
and i'm going to teach you how to cook
carbonara
have you ever made carbonara before no i
actually don't know i've probably eaten
it
maybe i could just get like one tip the
hardest thing about making carbonara is
making sure that you don't scramble the
eggs
oh that was gonna be the first thing i
was gonna do last thing i cooked was
top ramen and i took out all the water
so it was just noodles and then i forgot
to put the
seasoning in so that's the last thing i
ate when i was in my young 20s
and not really happy with my career i
decided to go back to school
i used my savings go to culinary school
and just thought you know if i have to
work for the next
40 years of my life i want to do
something i love i know how to make
yeah no i don't so this is a super quick
sauce so by the time the pasta is done
cooking
the sauce should be as well i know that
you are supposed to just
put a little bit of salt in the water
i don't know why i got a salt the water
so that you're seasoning the pasta as
well and it's an old saying that the
water should taste of the sea
you want to make sure there's a good
amount of water in your pot as well so
the pasta can move around freely in the
pot so now that the pasta is just
softening up in the water
it's just enough that i can start moving
it around and ensure that the pasta is
not sticking
so this is meat i'm going to cook it how
i cook bacon which is
to put it into a not hot pan
and then wait for it to get hot you get
it
even though the pancetta has a lot of
fat that's going to render out you still
want to use a little bit of olive oil
it can not only help get it going but
also to kind of make the sauce
go a little bit longer as well i like my
bacon extra crispy so i'm going to make
this extra crispy
bacon's a totally fine substitute for
this it's typically made with pureed
pork popcorn chalet
don't know what this cheese is parmesan
is from a cow's milk cheese so it's
going to be a little bit
more subtle than the pecorino romano and
that's why we're going to use two
different ones because the pecorino is
going to be a little bit tangier
and i'm pretty much going to go half and
half for this i'm also grating it on a
pretty small grater
because it's a hard cheese it's not
going to melt very well or at least
you know in comparison to something like
a mozzarella mozzarella right
okay it's probably not please be cooked
i'm just going to take it out now
i think it's cooked because i ate it and
doesn't taste raw
you don't want to go for super crunchy
dark
brown pancetta you want to make sure
that there's a little bit of bite there
still
put some egg yolks in here as well as a
few eggs
and to the eggs you want to add a bunch
of freshly ground black pepper there's a
lot of pasta
and a lot of pancetta on here so feel
free to go pretty bold with the pepper
in this recipe but again as always
cook for your taste oh shoot i'm gonna
put this back
in so what i'm gonna do is add a few
good handfuls of cheese to my eggs so
when i add the egg mixture to the hot
pasta it's not going to scramble right
away it has a little bit of that cheese
kind of protecting it
so some recipes have garlic some don't
so what i like to do is just kind of
knead it in the middle
and what i'll do is just kind of place
the garlic clove under my palm
and press down and what that's going to
do is just kind of break it and bruise
it a little bit
that's going to help release a lot of
that garlic flavor i mean how badly can
i actually mess this up we're both using
the same ingredients
all right let's make the sauce i'm going
to put this in and i'm just going to
wait a minute this can't be right this
cannot be right
i was told not this guy
you know what'll fix this is this cheese
right here
you gave me two eggs what else am i
supposed to do with them if i'm not
if i'm not supposed to scramble them i
know i scrambled them anyways but that's
because i was at a loss
really the only way to tell when pasta
is done is to taste it
so it's definitely al dente which is
good it still has a little bit of bite
to it
and that's actually perfect so if it's
already totally cooked all the way now
it's going to be overcooked by the time
you finish your sauce i'm going to go
ahead and try one
if i can at this point i'm going to turn
off the heat on this and actually kind
of put it off to the side just to ensure
that kind of quickly cooling everything
down so that when i add the eggs it
doesn't get overcooked
that hurt
[Music]
and it's okay that there's some water
that's draining off of this and getting
in here
like i said we're going to want a good
amount of pasta water in here anyways
this is right
i'm sure it's fine i'm just going to
kind of quickly stir this around
and even right away the pasta is going
to soak up a lot of extra water
so what i'll do is just add some of this
cooking pasta water in
i feel like i've made a misstep
somewhere so at this point i think i'm
ready to add
my egg mixture and you want to do this
pretty quickly so what you're going to
do is kind of
move the pot as you add this
this really doesn't need any fancy
technique all you're really trying to do
is just stir it around really quickly
and get a nice silky smooth texture
when it comes to cooking you sort of
just have to roll with the punches
especially if you don't know what you're
doing and i do not know what i am doing
so
boom the best thing to do before you
serve it to your guests
or just go eat it in front of the couch
is give it a little taste so to make
sure that the seasoning's right on it
[Music]
that footage is going to be deleted a
nice heaping amount
and sort of just twirl it on there a
little bit there's that twirl we're
looking for
get that on there if you want a little
bit of green at this point you could put
in a little bit of parsley here
and that is spaghetti carbonara and uh
you know there it is
am i wrong it looks like it's missing a
little bit of a sauce
but i mean there's no sauce yeah
let's give it a taste and see
yeah i mean all things considered it's
yeah it's good i mean you can see little
bits of egg kind of throughout but the
way you were describing it i was
thinking there was gonna be like massive
chunks there's a bit right there
a little bit i was trying not to throw
you under the bus
i mean it's edible i'd still eat it but
it's just i don't know
i don't know if i eat this she's got
green bits on hers
i didn't even get the green beans oh you
go for the one-handed method
what's the two-handed nothing like this
so ideally it should be a good balance
between the pepper two different kind of
salty tangy cheeses
the creamy egg and the pancetta if my
carbonara was what carbonara was
i wouldn't be into it i'm into this it's
very good now your next date you'll know
what to cook right
oh yes
[Music]
you